[Applause]
[Music]
my fellow americans
and the people who brought me the dance
delawareans
i see my buddy tom senator tom carper
down there and i think
i think senator coons is there and i
think the governor's around
is that ruth ann and that former
governor ruth ann minor
most importantly my sisters-in-law my
sister valerie
anyway
folks the people of this nation have
spoken
they've delivered us a clear victory
a convincing victory a victory
for we the people
we've won with the most votes ever cast
from presidential ticket
in the history of the nation 74 million
what i must admit is surprise me tonight
we're seeing all over this nation all
cities and all parts of the country
indeed across the world an outpouring of
joy
of hope renewed faith and tomorrow bring
a better day
and i'm humbled by the trust and
confidence
you've placed in me i pledge to be a
president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states and blue
states only sees the united states
and work with all my heart with the
confidence
of the whole people to win the
confidence of all of you
and for that is what america i believe
is about
it's about people and that's
what our administration will be all
about i sought this office
to restore the soul of america to
rebuild the backbone
of this nation the middle class and to
make america respected around the world
again
and to unite us here at home
it's the honor of my lifetime that so
many millions of americans have voted
for that vision
and now the work of making that vision
is real
it's a task the task of our time
folks as i said many times before
i'm jill's husband
and i would not be here without her love
and tireless support of jill
and my son hunter and ashley my daughter
and all our grandchildren
and their spouses and all our family
they're my heart joe's a mom a military
mom an educator
and she has dedicated her life to
education but teaching isn't just what
she does
it's who she is for american educators
this is a great day for you all
you're going to have one of your own in
the white house
and jill's going to make a great first
lady i'm so proud of
well her have the honor of serving with
a fantastic vice president
you just heard from kamala harris
who makes history as the first woman
first black woman the first woman from
south asian descent the first daughter
of an immigrant
ever elected in this country
don't tell me it's not possible in the
united states
it's long overdue and we're reminded
tonight
of those who fought so hard for so many
years
to make this happen but once again
america's bent the ark of the moral
universe more toward justice
kamala doug like it or not
your family you become an honorary bite
and there's no way out
to all those of you volunteered and
worked the polls
in the middle of pandemic local elected
officials
you deserve a special thanks from the
entire nation
and my campaign team and all the
volunteers
and all who gave so much of themselves
to make this moment possible
i owe you i owe you i owe you everything
and all those who supported us i'm proud
of the campaign we built and ran
i'm proud of the coalition we put
together the broadest
and most diverse coalition in history
democrats
republicans independents progressives
moderates conservatives
young old urban suburban rural
gay straight transgender white latino
asian
native american
i mean it especially those moments
and especially for those moments where
this campaign was at its lowest end
the african-american community stood up
again for a minute
[Applause]
and i'll have yours
[Applause]
i said at the outset i wanted to
represent this campaign to represent and
look
like america we've done that now that's
what the administration will look like
and act like for all those of you
who voted for president trump i
understand the disappointment tonight
i've lost a couple times myself but now
let's give each other a chance
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again and to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies
they are not our enemies they are
americans
they are americans
the bible tells us to everything there
is a season
a time to build a time to reap and a
time to sow
and a time to heal this is the time to
heal in america
now this campaign is over
what is the will of the people what is
our mandate
i believe it's this americans have
called upon us
to marshal the forces of decency the
forces of fairness
to marshal the forces of science and the
forces of hope
and the great battles of our time the
battle to control the virus
the battle of build prosperity the
battle to secure
your family's health care the battle to
achieve racial justice
and root out systemic racism in this
country
in the battle to save our planet by
getting climate under control
the battle restore decency defend
democracy
and give everybody in this country a
fair shot that's all they're asking for
a fair shot folks
our work begins with getting coveted
under control
we cannot repair the economy restore our
vitality
or relish life's most precious moments
hugging our grandchildren our children
our birthdays weddings graduations
all the moments that matter most to us
until we get it under control
on monday i will name a group of leading
scientists and experts
as transition advisors to help
take the biden-harris code plan and
convert it
into an action blueprint that will start
on january the 20th
2021
that plan will be built on bedrock
science
it will be constructed out of compassion
empathy and concern
i will spare no effort none
or any commitment to turn around
this pandemic folks
i'm a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who didn't
vote for me
as those who did
let this grim here of
demonization in america
begin to end here and now
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
it's not some mysterious force beyond
our control
it's a decision a choice we make
and if we can decide not to cooperate
then we can decide to cooperate
and i believe that this is part of the
mandate
given to us from the american people
they want us to cooperate
in their interest and that's the choice
i'll make
and i'll call on congress democrats
republicans alike
to make that choice with me the american
story
is about slow yet steadily widening the
opportunities in america
and make no mistake too many dreams have
been deferred for too long
we must make the promise of the country
real for everybody
no matter their race their ethnicity
their faith
their identity or their disability
folks america has always been shaped by
inflection points
by moments in time we've made hard
decisions about
who we are and what we want to be
lincoln in 1860 coming to save the union
fdr in 1932. promising a beleaguered
country
a new deal jfk
in 1960 pledging a new frontier
and 12 years ago when barack obama made
history he told us
yes we can
[Applause]
well we stand at an inflection point
we have an opportunity to defeat despair
to build a nation of prosperity and
purpose
we can do it i know we can i've long
talked about the battle
for the soul of america we must restore
the soul of america our nation is shaped
by the constant battle between our
better angels
and our darkest impulses and what
presidents say
in this battle matters it's time
for our better angels to prevail tonight
the whole world is watching america
and i believe at our best america is a
beacon for the globe
we will not leave we will lead not only
by the example of our power
but by the power of our example
i've always believed many of you heard
me say it
i've always believed we could define
america in one word
possibilities that
in america everyone should be given an
opportunity to go as far as their dreams
and god giving ability will take them
you see
i believe in the possibilities of this
country
we're always looking ahead ahead to an
america that's freer and more just
head to an america that creates jobs
with dignity and respect
ahead of america that cures diseases
like cancers
and alzheimer's ahead to an america that
never
leaves anyone behind a head of america
that
never gives up never gives in
this is a great nation it's always been
a bad bet to bet against america
we're good people this is the united
states of america
and there's never been anything never
been anything we've been able not able
to do
when we've done it together folks
in the last days of the campaign i began
thinking about a hymn
that means a lot to me and my family
particularly my deceased sun
bow it captures the faith that sustains
me
and which i believe sustains america and
i hope
and i hope it can provide some comfort
and solace the 230
million thousand americans who've lost a
loved one to this terrible virus this
year
my heart goes out to each and every one
of you hopefully this
him gives you solace as well it goes
like this
and he will raise you up on eagle's
wings
bear you on the breath of dawn and make
you to sign like the sun
and hold you in the palm of his hand
and now together on eagle's wings we
embark on the work
that god and history have called upon us
to do
with full hearts and steady hands
with faith in america and in each other
with love of country
a thirst for justice let us be the
nation that we know we can be
a nation united a nation strengthened a
nation healed
the united states america ladies and
gentlemen
there's never never been anything we've
tried we've not been able to do
so remember as my grandpa our grandpappy
sam and i walked out of his home
when i was a kid up in scranton he said
joey keep the faith
and our grandmother when she was alive
she yelled no joey spread it
spread the faith god love you all may
god bless america
and may god protect our church thank you
thank you thank you